uh good morning and welcome to this
meeting of mids suffk District Council
planning committee I'm councelor Sarah
Mansel and I will be chairing the
committee today may I first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please Ure that microphones are turned
off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave leave please ensure your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off and
that your laptops are switched to silent
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you intend to do so please could you
inform the committee clerk if you hear
the fire alarm leave the building
immediately via fire exit and make your
way to the assembly point at Ipswich
toown football ground follow the signs
directing you to the fire exits do not
re-enter the building until told it's
safe to do so so first of all we have
some introductions uh we have the
members of the committee who'll be
making the decisions on my right uh we
have the area planning manager Gemma
Walker um and some other planning
officers who will be taking the cases um
this morning we have our legal advisor
Ian dpre and his assistant um so we have
the case officers we've got Nikita
Mossman Braun Curtis will be joining um
on teams and Vincent Pier will be um
along later uh we also
have
um um
ail
gy just remembered her name um we have
my governance officer Alysia Norman
who'll be um making sure that I'm on
track uh we also have um other
governance officers Bethany Webb Mandy
Smith who will make sure the meeting's
in order and we have uh new member staff
Sammy Gibbs who's here observing
um thank
you so can I move to the agenda please
um number one apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any apologies
for absence thank you chair we have
apologies from councelor hadingham and
we have councelor Morgan substituting
thank you uh item number two to receive
Declarations of disclosable pecuniary
interest and other registerable or non
registrable interests by members are
there any to
declare councelor
Matson is it yeah um yes I need to
declare that I am acquainted with the
applicant for the um hemingstone
application that's the first one on the
agenda and in relation to the third
one I need to
declare that I'm a patient at need and
Market country
practice thank
you uh any other um
declarations uh thank you uh item number
three Declarations of lobbying are there
any to
declare um well I've had an email from
um I think it's the agent for Port one
did everyone get that
email um so I think we all have to
declare that as lobbying uh thank you
did you get get that councelor
Morgan so everybody apart from councelor
Morgan uh is there any other
lobbying um item number four
Declarations of personal site
visits uh Council
maton so obviously at um I have been to
the um applicant the first application
in hemingstone um a few times over the
many years is and I'm sure we've
probably all been to ston and
Barnes uh thank you uh well some of us
may have been ston and bond but not
necessarily for this application we did
all we did uh when we had the tour last
year we did visit part of Port one but
it wasn't specifically about this
application so I don't think that's
needs to be mentioned thank you um right
so item number five um
com sorry councel Hing
him having heard Council maton I should
declare that I do know um the site at
oldal Cottage uh I have been there once
or maybe
twice that's
all thank you uh so are we ready to move
on to item number five um MPL 2322
confirmation the minutes of the planning
committee held on the 20th of December
2023 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the
minutes uh could I have a proposal for
the
minutes uh Council hardingham thank you
an a seconder councilor Davis um and I
can we do this just with a show of hands
do you think for the minutes no you've
set it up already right um governance
officer will now conduct the electronic
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now open in modgv councelor Morgan
you want me to take your vote
verbally
uh thank you chair so that Mak six votes
for and two extensions that's carried
thank you um so the minutes of the
meeting are now approved uh they've been
confirmed and will be signed in due
course um item number six to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme n
received chair you item number seven we
move to the schedule of planning
applications we have three planning
applications today and we will be um
addressing them in the order listed on
the agenda um so we'll start with item
7A DC
23453 old Hall Cottage Main Road
hemingstone and I invite the case
officer Nikita Mossman to introduce the
application to committee over to you
Nikita thank you chair and good morning
members so this is application DC
23453 at Old Hall Cottage in hemingstone
the application seeks permission for the
conversion of and the extension to an
existing garage to provide ancillary
accommodation here is a site location
plan this shows the position of the
existing out building in relation to the
dwelling and how far the dwelling and
the out building is set back from the
highway this is the aerial map showing
the site in its context there is a
dwelling to the southeast of the site
but the surrounding area is
predominantly agricultural
land this is a wider view which shows
that there are some dwellings to the
north of the site as you go further down
Main Road but again this is most there
is mostly agricultural land surrounding
the
site this is the constraints map showing
that the host dwelling is a grade two
listed building and the old Hall Farm to
the southeast of the site is grade one
listed with a grade two listed building
on that plot too there is also a public
right of way which runs along the north
of the
site these are the existing plans of the
out building the drawings are labeled to
show that the existing materials are
painted render on the walls and clay
plane tiles on the
roof these are the proposed plans with
the section highlighted in yellow being
the extension and the section in white
being the existing it shows that the
extension turns the out building into an
L-shaped form the proposed materials are
to match the existing with painted
render and clay plane tiles The Proposal
also includes the removal of the
existing garage door and creates a door
in the South elevation in order to to
access the
building the top drawing shows the
existing floor plan this shows that the
out building is currently used as a
garageworkshop and the bottom drawing
shows the proposed floor plan which
utilizes the space in the existing part
of the out building for a kitchen and
sitting area and uses the extension for
a bedroom and wet
room this is the proposed block plan
showing the position of the extension on
the site
it also shows the parking Arrangement on
the site which with the existing access
to be
retained moving on to site photos this
is the front elevation of the host grto
listed dwelling and the front garden
area this is the position of the out
building in comparison to the dwelling
the out building is approximately 8 m
away from the
dwelling this is the front elevation of
the outbuilding building showing the
existing garage doors to be
removed this is the rear elevation where
the extension will be added onto to
create the L
shape and this is the side elevation
this is the elevation where the door is
to be put in to gain access into the
building this shows the path which runs
along the side of the out building and
leads to the
dwelling this is the a driveway facing
west and the proposed parking would be
on the left hand side of this
driveway this is the access Facing East
which is to be retained and the view
onto Main
Road this shows the ve vegetation along
the boundary when facing north and the
public right of way is on the other side
of
this and just another photo of the veg
of the
vegetation to conclude based on on the
information set out within the report
the recommendation is to Grant planning
permission subject to conditions thank
you uh thank you very much um do we have
any questions from members to the case
officer no questions um so I will now we
haven't got any public speakers for this
one have we so uh and we've had no
comment from anyone else so I now open
this item Up For Debate
um anybody wish to say
anything Council of War
boys doesn't seem to want to light
up oh it has now thank you um thank you
chair yeah yeah I have no issues with
this proposal at all I noticed in the
agenda supplement that the um Heritage
officer is now satisfied with the roof
finishes and wall finishes and notes
about external venting so I think that
was something that was wanting to be um
secured by condition but I'm not certain
looking at my notes um I think you look
at the previous planning applications
you see an ongoing program of repairs
and improvements to the property I think
it's a more interesting building perhaps
on the garage and workshop because you
got this and it and it makes it a more
livable space is in particular as you
got space now for a relative so I'm I'm
quite happy to support this
application thank you is that a proposal
it could be yes uh so unless you think
it's too soon but well um is anyone
willing to Second uh councilor warboy's
proposal councelor Morgan uh does anyone
have anything anything further to say on
this
application uh councilor mson yes just
to say that the um it seems entirely to
fit within our policies so um there
shouldn't be any problem with it at all
thank you and we do have a condition for
um ancillary to the main dwelling don't
we it's not going to become a separate
house it has to it has got that
restriction on which I think is
important um so if if no one else has
got anything to say uh councelor
Lawrence uh more query than anything
else is in the recommendations there's a
requirement for a secure and lit cycle
storage and EV charging prior to
occupation and I just wondered uh where
does that secur L cycle storage fit in
on the site and the EV charging point in
a grade two
listed area I don't know can the
officers has helped with can you put EV
charging and cycle storage on listed
buildings I think looking for a scheme
of how they would provide some cycle
parking obviously Liv in
the what okay we're losing the garage so
we looking at What alternative cycle
parking would be available that would be
up to the applicant to pop something
together for us uh could be in the
manner of a shed or cycle store for
something small scale and available for
secure cycle parking and in terms of EV
charging that is something we look at on
a caseby Case basis obviously if we've
got new dwellings we're looking for
something fairly substantial something
of this nature might be is there an
outdoor plug that is um got appropriate
ducting through that you you could run a
point to perhaps on this garage it's
right by the parking we're not looking
at putting a big box on the side of the
listed building but it would be up for
the applicant to be able to agree just
what that would look like
vorus just for clarity then for my
clarity anyway um we're not putting a
condition in there which the Heritage
team might in the future refuse so the
applicant is unable to comply with the
conditions that's there seems to be a
conflict in my view or potential
conflict I don't think we are looking at
works that would be a problem in the
setting of the listed building so the
plug on the side of the likely to be on
the side of the extension to the garage
that we're just looking at wouldn't have
any issues with Heritage Fabric and
wouldn't affect the character or
appearance of that small extension it
might be something you'd expect to see
of that nature so I think
that's fairly easily resolved and
similarly with secure and lit cycle
storage that is something like a shed or
cycle store something fairly small scale
or some other way of them saying yep
actually we store our bikes here and we
can do so so that shouldn't have the
impact and we can certainly run through
that so I think there are plenty of
options without having concern over the
listed building um thank you are are
there any further uh points to raise or
questions um if not then we'll go
straight to the vote I will ask the
government's officer to uh conduct the
electronic vote thank you thank you
chair members that vote is now in
progress thank you
e
thank you chair that makes eight votes
for so that is unanimous uh thank you
very much um so I think we can move um
straight on to item 7B thank you very
much Nikita um DC
24296 ston barns Peta Road ston aspel
um uh now is councelor right so
councelor H hardingham is the ward
member uh so he will just go and um sit
across the on the other side um and uh
part of the mids Constitution is that he
doesn't
vote um and uh we'll now invite the case
officer uh Braun Curtis uh who should be
with us on teams hello Braun you can
hear
us um yeah good morning so if you'd like
to introduce the application to
committee thank
you thank you chair and good morning
members okay I will start with the
presentation this is a little bit bit of
a complicated one because it is a
deferral but also in the time since your
previous meeting uh which some of you
were not members at the time or serving
on the committee at the time we've also
had the jlp so there's quite a bit in
the report um the site has a bit of
complex history about it as well so I
will try and give you a rundown of a bit
of everything but please do ask
questions um when I've sort of flipped
through everything and hopefully I'll
I'll give you an understanding of what
we're talking about
so application is for a pass of land um
forming part of the stonum barns complex
which is in the countryside between the
Villages of stonom masville and Peta
it's that little boot shaped section
which is the application
site it's just showing the context of
the two villages and the rights of bra
Network Highway Network
Etc this plan shows the site in relation
to some of the wider complex there's
actually been more development since
this plan was received which was a
couple of years
ago and I've included this plan please
ignore the red line here this is from a
slightly more recent application but it
gives you a sense of some of the of the
complex so ston and barns is a Leisure
and tourism complex it includes a couple
of fishing lakes um almost almost 200
Caravans some of which have um
restrictions on them for occupation for
Holiday L only some of them are for
security um Personnel some of them are
not controlled um for various reasons
there's also um foot golf Crazy Golf um
like a pitching part there's the mids
suffk show ground there's a conference
an event center a theater suff Al
Sanctuary um and a complex of retail um
and food type units in in Cen so there's
a a really mixed offering at the complex
as a whole um there's also um the former
Donkey Sanctuary land at bottom which is
also within their ownership and the
ownership goes off this slide um towards
Peta they own the land all the way up to
a property to and including Wayside
cottage which is sort of halfway between
the site and Peta I'll show you that in
some photos a little bit
later um as I said before there is a lot
of history at this site I've only
included the two most relevant
applications in the report because the
report would be twice as long if you had
all of the history but there is a lot
there has been a lot of different
applications for a lot of different
things on the whole the complex has
evolved in quite a peace meal way with
individual developments coming
forward um there has also been a lot of
enforcement investigation and action
through from both our planning
enforcement teams and our um
environmental health enforcement action
teams to do with various things um
across the years either unauthorized
development or developments not being
carried out in accordance with plans or
conditions um breaches of noise um
conditions working times and days things
like that so there's there's all of that
history as a backdrop to this
application not necessarily relevant to
the determination today but just so that
you have that context and what that also
gives you an idea of is the tension that
exists between the site operators and
the
community so moving
on I've included the extract from the
2015 plan because you can see in the
report that um the area of land that is
the subject of this application was
included in in the extent of the red
line for the 2015 permission on which we
did Grant the sighting of some Caravans
so the land in question has permission
to site approximately 11 Caravans in a
in a slightly different Arrangement and
things have happened in between 2015 and
now which which make things slightly but
the general principle of Caravans in
this location has already been
granted um and that forms part of the
reasoning from the landscape
professional so I'll talk about that in
a moment but just say that you've got
the two for
comparison and you have the layout of
the proposed here so slightly different
from the layout that had been granted in
2015 this is now for 18 Caravan units
arranged around uh sort of like a cerac
[Music]
end I've included um the layout for a
five Caravan extension to this part of
the complex which was granted in 2020
just um for context really and um to
speak about the precedent of that
decision at the
time some photographs of the site so at
the end of the existing extent of
cited Caravans you can see into the
agricultural field this is looking East
towards
Peta and then you can just see in the
very far background that's Wayside
Cottage so the highway along there you
can see the extent of open agricultural
land into which the site
[Music]
extends turning round so looking more
Eastward east
Southeast South and then turning back
towards the body of the complex and you
can see
the existing sighted Caravans some of
you can see some of the planting here
you can see some of the more mature
planting along the highway in the
background there there is a ditch that
runs along the southern boundary of the
site is shown there and then some
photographs from the road just show uh
some of the intermittent planting and
some of the views that there are from
the highway so you've got some hedge
planting some mature trees some
gaps get a sense of the backdrop of
existing complex of permitted Caravans
that are on the site as well and then
this is a photograph of high summer just
so that you can get a sense of how the
vegetation um grows at that time of
year uh this slide is included because
um there was a query um in the
representations about the capacity of
utilities to support the development and
that also came up at the previous
committee discussion so this shows the
location of uh um package treatment
plants for sewage the site is off Main
sewer which ends around 300 meters to to
the West in um the relig just on Asal so
it is entirely functioning on um septic
tanks and package treatment plants it
also has its own B holes for the
abstraction of
water um and it obviously has fishing
lakes etc for um which is for
firefighting ities as well as the
recreational purposes and we've had
advice from UK power networks to confirm
that the um electricity network has
capacity to support the development at
the
site so I've got some more recent photos
these were taken in November following
an enforcement um investigation visit so
again you can see the setting of the
existing Caravan Arrangement at that
part of the
site this just shows this is taken where
the first photos were showing bits of
agricultural field so you can now see
that some of some of the new Vans have
been sighted with pads being constructed
and the Vans sighted on them so these
two are new additional Caravans and then
you can see that there's two waiting in
the center background there so they are
placed on the S but they are not in
position in their final position and you
can see some of the construction works
for the pads being undertaken with this
this digger scraping the top soil to put
the pad down for those
vans and then I've included this
Photograph because again you can see
Wayside Cottage in the background there
but you can also see this Earth fund
which doesn't have planning permission
so it's unauthorized Works um it is
understood that the site operator has um
erected that in order to provide some
landscape screen screening but you'll
see that the advice that we've had from
the landscape professional is that
that's actually not helpful um it
introduces another um um obtrusive
feature and is not really the best way
to go about Landscaping the overall
visual impact of the complex but I'm
just adding it there so that you know it
exists in case
um you want to know that how it's
screened even though it's screened in an
unauthorized way so that's the end of
the photos I'm going to go back to
the layout picture and then I'll give
you a quick rundown of what it is that
you're considering again and what some
recommend
recommending so proposal is for the
continued use of land for the sighting
of 18 Caravans that would be as an
extension to the existing complex of
Caravans which are arranged around the
fishing lakes and are used for Holiday
accommodation um whilst your plan
provides for that
um as a specific policy providing for
tourist accommodation in the countryside
it is on the basis of there being um an
exceptional need and a demonstrated
business case and what's happened since
the deferral here is we went away and we
got the landscape advice to respond to
that that resolution from the deferral
um we also risk assessed once we had
that advice risk assessed that minded to
reason for refusal which was based on
the previous local plan and call
strategy but then we had the progress of
the joint local plan so we invited the
applicant to make submissions on the
basis of the joint local plan and how
they were responding to that as well as
responding to um you can see that
there's a holding objection from the
County Council um lead local flood
Authority on the basis of um
insufficient information to demonstrate
the management of surface water drainage
they have declined to provide any
information on that basis so whilst the
previous recommendation was one of
approval and whilst the principle of
development here for tourism development
in the countryside is provided for by
your plan your plan is now more specific
about requiring the demonstration of
that business case and the
exceptional which hasn't been provided
in this instance we also don't have the
information to demonstrate that the
development would meet the policy or
local policy and National policy
requirements in respect to flood risk so
being safe for its lifetime and not
increasing flood risk elsewhere with an
appropriate um drainage management
strategy and uh we also don't have any
information from the applicant on how
they intend to meet the requirements of
your policy lp16 for the delivery of
biodiversity net gain as I say we have
invited the applicant to respond on
those points they have declined we've
waited for quite a long time to bring
this to you in the hope that we might
get some Dialogue on that and we haven't
so we've we've brought it to you to make
a decision so your tabled paper just
adds a little bit more to my assessment
to make it clear on the points about
principle of development but it not
being demonstrated that it meets all of
the um requirements in the
policy that there's no demonstration of
um compliance with policies relating to
flood risk or biodiversity net gain and
an updated recommendation so refusal but
on three for three
reasons I'll leave it there for a moment
thank you uh thank you um do we have any
questions from
Members
um uh councelor
Elkin thank you um Brun hopefully you
can hear me all right um the you said
that they've been given ample
opportunity to to respond on the
biodiversity net gain and flood risk and
the business case I just wondered um you
know had they been given sort of extra
time um is there any sort of extenuating
circumstances why they haven't
responded the um so as you know the
consultation on joint local plan uh went
through quite a long period of of public
consultation and the agent for this
application engaged in that consultation
and made representation specifically
relating to ston and
bars this application has been with us
for four years um that dialogue has been
ongoing as the progress of the jlp has
has moved through that time I don't
believe there's um any reason why there
would be any different treatment of this
application than any
other certainly none that they brought
to my attention
anyway uh any further
questions no uh Council
Lawrence just from my own Clarity on
this particular number of
18 did I read it wrong but 11 have
already got permission is that
correct so we're talking about that's
correct we're talking about an
additional
seven that's correct so the 2015
permission included the arrangement of
some Caravans in this location
uh a slightly different layout but 11
more or less on this parcel of land and
the proposal is for 18 so can I just
have a bit more clarification so the
suggested con uh reasons for refusal
only relate to the additional seven then
not the whole
18 18 because that's what's being
applied for and we're considering this
application as a whole but when you're
dealing with weighing the the difference
between what has permission and what's
being applied for then it is material to
bear that they have permission to site
11 under a preious permission however I
should say that there is some
uncertainty about which permissions they
can rely on we are in the process of
working with our enforcement team uh
following the hillside Parks judgment
and other judgments of the previous
couple of years to
confirm with them which permissions
they're relying on for what developments
that are on the site um the agent has
said that they are going to be providing
that information to us so we are waiting
for that but in the meantime that
doesn't prevent members from determining
this
application uh councelor War
boys
thank you chair and
soon
um yeah yes um our
initial uh minding to refuse was very
much around the sort of uh Visual and
Landscape impact uh
the um landscape reporters sort of said
that this would be there' be an
acceptable level of visual impact within
the sort of nature of the development of
the site as a whole and and what's been
going on however within that the it did
say there were opport we could condition
opportunities to secure some mitigation
of visual effects plus improve quality
and character of the area um your your
slides from the presentation are are
really sort of do do sort of show what
the character of the area is at present
is it possible I you've got three quite
specific reasons for refusal here is it
possible to
include this
as that there's been no um effort to
secure some mitigation of visual effects
or improve the quality and character of
the
area it might be worth my clarifying
that the instruction to the landscape
professional was not just in response to
the deferral resolution but I did ask
her to consider the potential for future
development on all of the land between
the existing complex and the rest of
their ownership up to Wayside Cottage
because I expect there to be more
applications come forward it was an
expensive piece of work and I thought
whilst she was out there assessing
visual impact I would ask her a series
of questions so the scope of the
response deals more with than than just
the impact of this
development it deals with the potential
for other development and the
opportunities that the authority has to
control the visual impact of that
development through uh further landscape
mitigation and you'll note in the full
text of the response that um she speaks
about there being Woodland planting
along the roadside and she particularly
criticizes the the bond so whilst there
is an opportunity to do that if we're
going to be looking to to Grant
permission and um and Del secure that
through the delivery of another
development the risk of refusing this
proposal on the basis of visual impact
I've assessed as
um in the report and I've said that we
shouldn't be using that as a reason for
refusal I think that makes sense did did
that help councilor War I think so thank
you thank you any further questions
s uh no thank you so um uh I now invite
the public speakers to address the
committee I I understand that the parish
council can't uh be here today uh but
councelor hardingham is going to read
the response from the parish council uh
so I will time it with my three minute
timer uh thank you councilor
hardingham thank you chair um this is a
statement on behalf of ston mpo Parish
Council
the parish council objects to this
application on the following grounds the
application is requesting additional
static Caravans over and above the 200
that have permission from the original
hybrid application and subsequent
applications that have been granted this
we believe constitutes a massive
overdevelopment in the
countryside locally the site is known as
the prisoner of war camp as it blights
not only our Parish but also the
adjoining parishes
of PETA and
Crowfield the parish council and local
community are aware that the vast
majority of the static Caravans are used
by the occupiers as their main or
primary residence and not as holiday
accommodation in contradiction of
planning condition 20 of the original
hybrid
application this therefore potentially
constitutes a population that is nearly
the size of stonom Asal Village itself
uh which is designated as a secondary
settlement however the parish council
has a great deal of sympathy with the
planning enforcement team as they do not
have the legal powers to investigate
fully the occupation status of occupiers
having to heavily rely on the honesty of
both occupier and site owner these
occupiers are invisible to midu and
suffer County councils as they do not
appear on the Electoral register no
council tax is paid by the occupier and
the local authorities can accurately
fund their social health and other
residential
commitments the site is not connected to
the Village sewer system therefore all
foul water has to be managed by packet
treatment plants which we Rel that
number is now in double figures the
upshot is that these treatment plants
have limitations on the volumes of foul
water that can handle and the types of
solid waste they can process on a
regular basis local residents static
caravan occupiers complain of bad smells
being emitted from the site and from the
outflow pipes that adjoin the site with
neighboring
Fields environmental health are aware of
the issues but deem it low priority in
their burgeoning case
load there is a continuing and worsening
environmental impact from the growing
number of static Caravans on the site
they're not subject to the same
requirements as housing developments and
all cooking and heating provision is
provided by LPG
gas with static Caravans having on the
site uh an internal footprint of up to
1200 square ft LPG usage will be
consistent with heating and cooking for
a large three-bedroomed
house multiply the gas usage by 200 and
the environmental impact can be easily
proved finally this application fails to
demonstrate an overriding business need
for the development such as would be
considered an exceptional circumstance
for the purposes of policy
lp13 of the recently implemented
jlp as such the principle of the de
development is in conflict with the
development plan and should be refused
uh thank you um the parish council
representative isn't here to answer any
questions so I suggest if we have any
questions uh we ask that when the ward
member makes his own
representation um we don't have an
objector we don't have a supporter uh I
believe we have the applicant of of the
agent sorry uh Mr Phil Cobalt um if you
would like to um make your
representation I will time you with my
three minute timer thank you thank you
if I could first of all refer you to
paragraph 34 of the officer's report
which lists the policies which they
believe are relevant to the
application that list admits a number of
policies firstly it admits reference to
policy spo7 which is your strategic
policy for tourism which states new
sustainable tourism development that
supports the tourism role of the
settlements across Baba and mid stuff
will be encouraged where appropriate to
the scale character and nature of the
locality this proposal is sustainable as
the site is accessible by public
transport there are bus stops outside
the site entrance and according to the
County Council website these are served
by four daily services to ipswitch there
are also a range of shops and Facilities
on site so guests would not be reliant
on the use of a
car policy lp12 is also emitted from
your report this also deals with tourism
and Leisure it states proposals for new
tourism and Leisure facilities or
improvements SL extensions to existing
facilities will be supported where they
improve the district's ability to
attract and cater for visitors this
ticks that box where they improve the
Range quality and accessibility of
facilities this proposal ticks this that
box where they are accessible by public
transport and facilities for walk and
cycling again this proposal ticks that
box and where they include facilities
which are open to The Wider Community
also Accords with that
criteria policy lp13 deals with
Countryside tourism accommodation it
states outside settlement boundaries
applications for tourist accommodation
will be considered on an exceptional
basis in addition applications must
demonstrate an overriding business need
to be in that location be sympathetic to
the character and be accessible by a
range of of Transport modes the pretext
to that policy does not explain why
tourist accommodation can only be
approved on an exceptional basis nor
does it g give any guidance at all on
what would constitute an overriding
business need in this case the existing
building the existing building sorry the
existing business is in the countryside
therefore clearly any expansion of that
business will also have to be in the
countryside your officer report also
contains no mention of the council's
visitor destination plan which
emphasizes the need to encourage more
over overnight stays and for visitors to
come all year round there's also no
mention of the council's recently
adopted culture Heritage and visitor
economy strategy one of the objectives
of which is to support diversification
of the local visitor to offer especially
accommodation infrastructure and to
proactively support new
developments the report also contains no
Comm ments from the council's economic
development and touring tourism officer
which is
surprising with regards to the objection
to flooding we submitted a comprehensive
flood risk assessment when the County
Council flood team requested further
information we responded in February
last year to all of their queries they
still maintain a holding objection but
they have not explained why or how the
information we've submitted is
sufficient deficient the site is within
flood zone one which means it's not at
risk of um of flooding and and the EA
Maps also confirm that the site is not
at risk of surface flooding so that's
difficult to understand who or what
would be at risk we are confident that
our flood risk assessment is robust are
you almost at the end yes sure just like
to finish with your final sentence
please having declared a climate
emergency surely the council should be
encouraging people from other parts of
the country to visit mids suffk rather
than fly abroad for their holidays
especially as this site is accessible by
public transport
uh thank you uh do we have any questions
uh for the
agent any questions for the
agent um well I I just like to to ask
because my ears pricked up when you
mentioned how opportunities of cycling I
personally don't like cycling on the
a120 so I wondered if you could explain
what the opportunities of cycling to and
from the site
were opportunities there's a bus stop
directly opposite the
entrance sorry I must have misheard you
I thought you mentioned opportunities
for walking in cycling I think that's
what the policy referred to I was
emphasizing that there's public
transport available to the site
okay I mean I I'd just like to um uh
maybe ask the officer about the comment
uh Mr kobo's made about the response to
the flood Authority I know that's suff
County Council but but uh there
obviously seems to be a bit of a a
conflict here if um one side thinks they
have supplied the information and um s
County Council don't so I wondered if
you could um make any comment on that
thank
you thank you chair excuse me uh so the
advice that we have from the lead local
flood Authority whose responsibility it
is to advise on the engineering capacity
Etc of um surface water flood risk is
that they have a holding objection that
there is insufficient information to
enable them to
comment uh that then makes it difficult
for us to come to any conclusion as to
whether or not the application
submission complies with our policies in
relation to flood risk and the um
precautionary principle applies when
we're dealing with flood risks basically
we should be looking at the the worst
case scenario when it's it's something
that has potential to affect property in
life so in the absence of information we
should
refuse but if the applicant can
demonstrate the information that the
lead local flood Authority are asking
for it's very likely that that reason
for refusal could be
overcome thank you uh any further
questions um of Mr cobal uh thank you Mr
cobal um so uh We've now got the ward
member councelor hardingham um if you'd
like to make any um representation about
this application thank you thank you
chair um I really have very little to
add to what our case officer has already
said um she's been extremely careful in
wording her advice to us um and to um
not rely on the landscape um arguments
that were um originally listed when the
application was deferred by the
committee in
2021 um and her advice is that we should
rely purely on the the the three um um
reasons that she's given um and of which
the main one is the lp13 business case
argument um I would just add that in
terms of flooding and flood risk uh the
house immediately adjacent stolin barns
um was flooded to a depth of a couple of
feet um during storm babbit um I re I I
appreciate that the water came from
across the road from the field the other
side um but nevertheless the whole area
although it's one of the highest places
in suffk and so you would immediately
assume flood zone one and no risk of
flooding um because it's relatively flat
uh and the ditches and water courses up
there are not particularly adapted to
the extremely heavy rainfall that we've
been having um they simply haven't been
able to cope and so flooding has been
cropping up in places where it wouldn't
normally be expected um and in the past
that house is also flooded uh with water
coming off the stolen bar site so um
there is a flood risk associated with
with development up there thank you
thank you um are there any questions of
the ward member uh Cel M yeah can can
the officer identify which um which
residential property is the that um
council hardingham is referring to
getting flooded um
in recent
months I believe Council hardingham
please correct me if I'm wrong I believe
you're referring to brambley
hedge which
case that's probably the best one is
that one in that little triangle it's on
the a
1120 I'll just try and turn that Cod C
I'm not sure we're seeing the screen you
think we're seeing Brun we've got the
site plan with the Caravan layer on it
still
sorry there we go um and I'm going to
try and change my pointer to laser point
there we go R hedg is
there yeah thank you yes um yeah I'm I'm
recalling that that the flooding of that
property was an issue uh in one of the
earlier um visits of son and Bar's um
applications to
committee um so and is Council Harding
is saying I mean the problem isn't it's
anywhere near the river the problem is
when there's a lot of rain it's flat and
it does the water doesn't get away
generally where's the flooding coming
from uh in this case in during storm B
rbit it came uh I believe from across
the road uh from a field which is high
higher than than the road on to the
north um and um there there are gullies
in the road which drain underneath
stolen bar site and out to the South um
but they were simply not up to the task
um and in the past there has been
flooding coming from from the ston and
bar site that issue may or may not have
been fixed I don't
know
uh thank you uh any further
questions anyone else got any questions
I would like to ask uh councilor
hardingham about the bus service which
the agent referred to um I think he said
there were four buses a day uh do they
go to places that maybe holiday makers
might want to go and are they a sort of
sensible time of day that you could
actually make use of them thank you uh
I'm afraid I can't give you that
information uh I'm sorry but I'm not
well acquainted with the bus service
Services um I suspect they are very
local services in Stow Market but the
agent May well be able to
elaborate with the rail
service any further questions of the uh
uh Ward member um if not then we'll open
this item Up For Debate um who would
like to make a comment
first C Matson yeah well I um I was a
member of the committee uh in the um
2021 um
deferral um and as you members will have
read the the risk assessment you can see
that that there was that
particular um unhappiness on the part of
the committee about about the landscape
impact I I just just wanted to can we go
to slide seven
please just just so that people
can understand the the the
problem
um
the if if you think about ston and
Barnes as as a sort of a a village which
it more or less is in a way um the
the the the the Caravans on the left of
that that diagram um they are
essentially one side of of a of a a
cluster of of Caravans and Retail and
other activities the officers have
described um and the problem that we had
and we we were disappointed to find that
that half of the extension of the
Caravans across the across there um had
effect L already
been
approved
and that they were really an extension
into the countryside in a way that the
the cluster was not and so committee was
was very keen to to limit
that harm as we saw it but as you see
the the landscape assessment has not
entirely supported that but you can see
why
less Caravans is better than more
Caravans um because it extends further
and further away from you know if this
was a village and we were talking about
an outline application we'd be saying
well it it needs to fit more comfortably
with the the existing settlement not
stick
out a Long Way East East I think it is
um so yeah that's just to explain
explain the reasons why so I think I I
would have no hesitation in not wanting
to increase the 11 to
18 um even if the piece of land is the
same because it it just increases that
um in my view harm which is um you know
not entirely supported by the the risk
assessment that we've had so that's
that's the my about it that LE less will
be always better than more um I think
the other thing to say and this
is difficult and contentious is that the
the apparent demand for even
more that that almost 200 that was that
was quoted by the officer of
Caravans um I don't know what the split
of that is in planning terms between um
holiday accommodation and Resident
permanent residential accommodation but
certainly the um Enforcement
cases I
think probably a year and a half two
years ago particularly were very much
about the fact that were what was
supposed to be holiday
accommodation was being used as
permanent residents in fact there were
there were people on the Electoral
register to vote
who were living in
Holiday accommodation so I'm a little
bit concerned that the the business
case which hasn't been put forward at
the moment really but that the business
case is effectively being supported by
um more permanent residents than is
either permitted or or or desirable
really um we've refused other car van
applications in great Bret because we
didn't think that having 100 odd
Caravans um in permanent residential use
in one place uh was was desirable and we
refused it and I think that that's I
think that refusal was uphold held
appeal J great Bryce it not
sure memory I think was but I wouldn't
I'd like to check before giving an
answer that so so so we can we can see
that
that the council view that having a very
large number of of Caravans in one place
in permanent residence is not a good
idea so you know the risk is that we
will be having more enforcement
difficulties because people desperate
for somewhere to live um will take on
these these Caravans even though they're
supposed to to not live in them more
than 11 months of the
year thank you um anyone else wish to um
make a comment or all their views uh
councelor
Davis thank you chair um yeah I clearly
wish to support the tourism industry and
local uh jobs in our district however
it's really disappointing to see the
lack of Engagement in producing an
overall plan for the business
development of this area and clearly
there are a number of issues which
um raise concerns
so
uh for me not having any information at
all and any wish
to uh apply the biodiversity net gain
which is uh
increasingly needed by applicants is
further disappointment so I feel unable
to support
um this application for 18 homes of
mobile homes thank you uh anyone else
wish to um make any comments or
proposals thank
you thank you I mean yes just to sort of
Follow that really I just find it a bit
confusing that there's it's clearly a
large site with lots of space in terms
of what could be provided in terms of
biodiversity net gain that would add to
the the value of the site for tourists I
would have thought and make it more
attractive as well as being beneficial
for for wildlife it just seems confusing
that there hasn't been any offer or any
engagement on that so um and for the
other reasons mentioned um without the
business case information I mean I would
hope I think the developer mentioned
that they weren't clear what they needed
to provide so hopefully there can be you
know that can be provided and there can
be engagement with the officers to
clarify that but yeah as other others
have said in its current form I wouldn't
feel comfortable supporting that thank
you uh anyone else uh councilor
Lawrence I I was big I didn't quite
follow quite a few of the arguments that
the agent was putting forward um
policies that weren't included by the
case officer um a lot of the issues in
my view that were discussed by the agent
in that um
presentation were rather frivolous in
that um the enhancements or improvements
didn't really imply to the greater
communities of the nearby Villages or to
others it was really enh enhancements
for the benefit of the applicant and and
to suggest that people won't fly abroad
um but would rather catch a train to
ipswitch and then a bus from ipswitch
out to this site with masses of
suitcases I I just find uh mind-blowing
thank
you uh thank you
anyone else wish to say anything or um
we don't have any proposals uh been put
forward Che councilor
Morgan I'd just like to reiterate
councelor Elkin's feelings about the
lack of response from the applicant This
concerns me um and also the concern of
permanent dwellings exceeding the amount
and evasion of councel tax thereof it is
an element of concern to me
so therefore I am against
it thank you uh councelor mats did I see
you waving again yes yes um yeah I would
like to make a proposal to um refuse in
line with the officer's
recommendations thank you and that's the
officer's recommendations on the um
additional papers the supplementary
papers yes just checking that we're all
looking at the same list of um reasons
for refusal yeah yeah so that is page
five and six of the supplementary papers
okay thank you do we have a second
councilor Davis are you I would be happy
to second that proposal yes uh thank you
does anyone else wish to um say anything
about this proposal to go along with the
officer recommendation for refusal on
those um three main um reasons listed on
page five and
six no okay so I will then ask the um
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress on
modgv councelor Morgan do you want me to
take your vote verbally
please yeah just to remind people we're
voting um it's a vote it's a refusal so
for will mean you're voting for
refusal
uh thank you chair so that makes seven
votes for that's unanimous uh thank you
thank you very much um so uh we'll now
take a um uh was it let's meet back
we'll take a break here for Comfort
break so can we come back here at 52 so
we' got six minutes is that enough
item 7c DC
22628 at Port one business and Logistics
Park
brownford Road little blenham uh and I
will now invite the case officer Vincent
Pierce to introduce the application
committee thank you thank you chair good
morning members and members of the
audience and anyone who may be watching
or listening from home as the chair says
we're looking this morning at a hybrid
application and that contains two
elements full application for three
Warehouse units and Associated access
and Landscaping and an outline
application for the expansion further
expansion of Port one the logistics
Park as you can see from the screen the
majority of the port one site sits
within little blakenham there's a small
pocket that sits in great
blenham but the part that sits in great
Blum is essentially the phase one
development that's already under well
almost completed now at the top of the
screen you'll see a red flashing area
that's the gipping meadow l land that's
the land that if the committee was
minded to Grant permission would become
a nature area some 8.8 hectares and
potentially could be available for
transfer to the council for a
pound application includes full
application as I say for three Warehouse
units outline application for what is
shown indicatively as six more Warehouse
units it includes improvements to
Junction 52 on the
A14 as we as I said it provides for
significant biodiversity
enhancement and it contains a much wider
I've called it a green package and I've
put the highlights on the screen but the
report goes into this in far more detail
so what is Port one I suspect most
members are now very familiar with it
but it is a highly successful
purpose-built
Logistics Park in gra
Laken it's also a Freeport Customs area
which provides it with certain tax
advantages that are proving very
attractive to inward
investment and of course it is on the
A14 which is a
strategic Highway Corridor particularly
for goods
Vehicles so on the screen the area in
turquoise is the area where the full
application applies so that includes the
Landscaping to to brownford Road it
includes a new access completely new
access from brownford road and it
includes three Warehouse
units the magenta color is the outline
area and whilst we have a layout on the
screen that isn't necessarily the layout
that would come in Via Reserve matters
if members were minded to Grant
permission it is purely indicative but
as you can see it follows the general
pattern of existing development now
within phase one
so if we quickly look at how the access
would work if you were coming off the
A14 you would swing down into the new
new access if you wanted to
leave again you'd use the new access to
directly access Junction
52 the point of the layout arrangements
and Highway management techniques that
are used for this axis is to try and
prevent hdv movements
North and South along the brownford road
through some of the residential areas so
what we're trying to do is focus all hgv
movements onto the A14 in the quickest
way we
can so in terms of coming down brownford
Road you'd have to swing left Round the
roundabout and come back in this is
simply to get maximum benefit for
capacity so going northwards you
wouldn't be able to swing in left into
the new access what that looks like here
we have a a computer aided simulation so
we're now looking southwards along the
brownford road and that Lorry is about
to swing into the new
access as I said this is a completely
new Junction so you'd come
in onto a new spine road that will serve
the logistics part you'll have Warehouse
units to your left and
right
potentially there could be a barrier
here to um enhance
security because obviously there a
customs area the applicant has to meet
certain criteria to ensure that Goods
coming in are
secure and then if you we swing left and
you look down to the outline application
part of this proposal and if we swing
right we see what is the full
application area and then phase one
Beyond
so there we start to see and then that's
phase one looking into the the distance
so in terms of the full application
we're looking at unit
5 unit 11 and unit
12 this is a typical elevation um one
end of the building has a lot of Glass
and Metal very similar to the format
that we've already approved in Phase One
and the banding Shades from very light
gray to site as shown and we've all
agreed that's the best uh arrangement of
of banding in order to minimize the bulk
of these units in the long views from
the east from the Barum cayen Direction
because behind this is actually a
backdrop of trees mature trees within
the blam
estate this side actually sits low lower
than the Blake estate land significantly
lower
again some more typical
elevations quick shot of what goes on
inside for those that haven't been
inside state-of-the-art uh warehousing
nine racks High floor to
ceiling quite a bit of automation but
there is a significant amount of job
creation in within this scheme as you'll
see from the report when it's all
working at maximum capacity assuming get
per Mission this and phase one could
generate rate up to 1250 jobs but even
taking a conservative estimate on on job
numbers it's still in the many hundreds
and is is a significant amount just to
show you the difference in building
Heights and ground levels between the
detailed application before you and what
we approved previously so here we have
sorry I'm doing that again you're over
that way here we have phase
one what we have here is now the the new
phase two and as you can
see this is significantly lower than
this
because a significant amount of land has
now been has been excavated as part of
the previous planning permission so what
we're trying to do all the time is to
lower the mass of these
buildings in the views so average floor
to Ridge height is about 20 me met but
by sinking it into the ground you
immediately reduce the impact on the
visual impact of
those here's it here you can see
literally the difference in level so
that red dashed line is The Edge at the
moment phase one is to the
right the second part of phase one is
being excavated and you can see the drop
and you can also see the retaining
structures that are are going in and
here you can see
the Woodland the plantation that's part
of the blenham estate oh
Sor is it better if I do it on that one
so you can see how by reducing the
levels the buildings will sit below the
tops of those
trees that's why the darker bands of the
building at the top rather than the
lighter
bands some more
cross-sections we have conditioned this
particular Bund just to make sure that
the angle of what we call the angle of
repose this
one is structurally stable and we've
conditioned that so it might need to be
something more akin to that although as
you can see we have successfully
approved some fairly steep retaining
walls within phase one so as long as
they're structurally sound and we'll
have that all checked we have no concern
about retaining
structures
here we
have pound
Lane which is existing road to the South
that separates the application site from
the existing tomato growing
Warehouse as you can see from this angle
with the existing trees some raise
levels and additional
planting you won't really catch a sight
of the end of this Warehouse bearing in
mind it's still indicative from from
pound Lane pound Lane still retains
quite a typical Country Lane character
and that's something we've tried to
ensure that we
keep despite the fact that we are
suggesting extending this large
Logistics park it is what it is as I say
in the report but I am suggesting in the
central green Corridor which I identify
in the
report I'm thinking it might be better
to reverse the banding so that as you're
walking
along the green Corridor which contains
a designated public footpath I'm just
going to reverse the
colors just for that section right
through the middle and what that might
do is reduce the sense of presence
perhaps the dominance to Walkers of
those those buildings because the
lighter colors will go up towards the
sky that's what you'll be experiencing
but again that could be conditioned how
that might look in relation to the other
banding we'd have to to think about but
it is quite wide it is 72 feet 22 M
which is two coach
lengths and that will be heavily planted
so I my feeling is that the visual
impact of those wherehouse edges will be
significantly
softened here we have another fly
through so this is Phase One we're
actually at the uh Northern end of phase
one I'm just going to fly you
around so you can see the extent of
planting within the blam State we simply
drop down because that's mounded already
as part of the phase one
works and if that will then
swing in the direction of pound Lane so
you you see the energy from waste plant
in the distance you see buildings in
phase one and then we start to move
towards phase
two and you can start to see the central
boulevards how they're
arranged they're actually arranged at
right angles to brownford road to reduce
the impact on views from brownford Road
it's been very carefully thought through
a lot of emphasis on planting within the
scheme even though it is a logistics
Park just swing around we're looking
back towards the energy from
waste building we swing around it is
what it is it's a it's a high-tech
state-of-the-art Logistics
Park and then we look back
towards Blake and
Plantation uh a really good feature of
this so far in Port one is the amount of
EV charging that's been installed you'll
remember that your normal standard is
one per five spaces in places we're
getting close to 50%
and as part of um K and de's Ethos what
they are trying to do is encourage as
much use of electric vehicles as
possible by really increasing the number
of charging facilities within their
development we would expect that to
continue into phase two were you minded
to Grant
permission so here we have a quick slide
showing the cycle parking facilities if
we blow that up you can see that there's
a significant number of uh spaces being
provided so that's what 228 and another
50 that's uh over 300
spaces just within the detailed element
so as well as the emphasis on green
electric power usage they are also
providing putting an emphasis on cycling
that isn't simply by providing large
numbers of cycle stands off cycle
shelters it's also by extending the
cycle Network in and around great
blenham and we'll have some slides on
that
shortly so here we have the outline
application era and again as I say this
is purely indicative so where you mind
you to Grant planning permission what
would happen is the applicant would
submit Reserve matters we' get all the
details and then it would come back to
the committee in just the same way as
you've seen all the details for units 5
11 and 12 so what you're look thinking
about in terms of the magenta area is
simply the principle of development
rather than the full details which only
relates to 5 11 and and
12 so what is the cycle Network position
like in this area
so phase one provided extended Network
North from what was then the new access
which is black Acre Road it also
includes a crossing
point on on brownford road so that you
can actually cross the road now safely
at the Crossing Point that road or the
the cycle Network extends to the new
residential areas towards um I forget
the name actual name of it but it's the
Pimon development so what we were trying
to do is provide not just cycle uh
connections but pedestrian connections
from the new residential developments in
order to make this an attractive place
to work and in a way that you wouldn't
have to use your are to access it as
part of phase two if you're minded to
ground planning position the cycle
network is further extended down from
the existing one right the way down to
the new access and Beyond and it
includes a crossing over the brownford
road anyone who's well you can see from
the report at the moment it's simply a
well-worn piece of grass in the central
reservation with some drop
curves this would be a
signalized junction so again enhancing
the network and making the site more
accessible to people who live in the
area and then within the development we
have a an extensive network of cycle
footways in order to allow members of
staff and visitors to continue their
Journey safely to the the units in which
they want to visit or
work here in aerial shot in the yellow
dashed dotted line is the phase one
improvements
and in the slides you
can
see here and here how that network was
extended The Wider Network shown on the
screen the sort of mustard colored um
areas are cycle networks within
residential developments in new
residential developments the committee
is ensuring that we do get enhanced
cycle
networks what we've tried to do with ort
one is to link them to the jobs via
extensions to the cycle
Network we have achieved that very
successfully here at Port Port one in
terms of the LC
whip the actual desire line from great
Blum to Clayton is along Station Road so
if we
superimpose so that's uh Station Road
that goes under the A14 and we've got
some slides so what we're actually doing
is enhancing what you've already put
into the LC whd in order to provide a
Spur through
here and there's a shot of um Station
Road so when you it's quite wide under
the bridge at places it it pinches but
it does provide an alternative route to
clayon that doesn't have to go around
Junction 52
in terms of Suds and drainage what we
have secured is a network of lagoons
along the Eastern edge of the site and
our ecologists have become very excited
at the prospect of doing something
really Innovative in terms of the
planting uh members will be familiar
with the old style of basins that were
simply a rectangular hollow grassed
hollow that were they looked highly
engineered what we are doing here
working with Ken de we just take you
slowly through that it's set within
landscape it's irregular in shape but it
will provide the capacity necessary to
take all the surface water drainage and
from the
development but we are looking to create
a network of Wet
Woods and these are typically the sort
of uh landscape and ecology you would
find along flood Plaines Rivers if it
was left to its own devices so in some
ways this looks a bit primordial but
elsewhere we've started to secure Wet
Woods of this nature with dead tree
trunks in it and all sorts of things the
idea is that it it provides all the
necessary drainage capacity but it does
it in a way that is particularly
attractive to Wildlife and particularly
Wildlife that relies on Wet Woods it's a
scarce resource and this is a way of
really boosting
biodiversity so we are encouraged by the
applicants Innovative approach and the
fact that they want to work with us to
achieve this level of of I was going to
say Delight but it is actually something
really quite beautiful if it works as
intended extensive Landscaping included
in this this proposal I won't go through
all the details but as you can see the
margins are heavily landscaped what I
have suggested is we have a condition
that requires further details of this
section to be
provided simply to ensure that that
relationship I showed you in
cross-section so that if you on pound
Lane you wouldn't see the the end of the
building behind I'm confident we can
achieve that both in terms of the level
differences because pound Lane is
already in a cutting
but I think it's just prudent to make
sure that we have control over those
conditions going
forward a huge planting list and as you
you won't be able to see what's on that
but what I've tried to do is simply if
it's going to work is to
blow just I just draw your eye to some
of the numbers here over 2,000 field
Maples obviously they're not going to be
uh extra heavy standards but
644 or Thorns that's just on one part of
the site it's an enormous planting list
and anyone who's been out to phase one
of Port one will see that the density of
planting is high it's
incredible there's no reason to S to
suspect that that won't continue and
just from that list I haven't counted
them up but there must be over
20,000 plants going in there'll also be
a significant number of trees so it's
not all
whips just a typical extract just to
give you some idea of the types of
planting this is the new access so here
we've got a a mixture of Oak lime and
Elm interestingly as disease resistant
as you can
currently buy so it's a it's Dutch Elm
resistant species of elm it would be
nice to start seeing some Elms coming
back into the the landscape but of
course there would be a condition
requiring replanting so if for some
reason the Elms didn't succeed we could
for five years require replacement and I
think even the um I don't say even the
applicant themselves want to make sure
that the a shop window to their
development was as as amazing as
possible so I'm quite happy that that
level of detail will be followed through
the management plan the Landscape
Management
plan so we've we've already had that fly
through Junction
52 of all the aspects of this
development that caused most concern at
the start of this process with the
parish councils was what will the impact
be on Junction 52 there was a a strong
feeling that it could
easily uh bring the junction to a
standstill well clearly advice from suff
County Council is that wouldn't have
been the case but what we have done is
work with suffer County highways the
applicant to secure improvements so at
the
moment the area the approach with the
black circle looks like that left on the
left hand lane Straight Ahead the
forward Lane that will be
amended in order to give notice that
this section will now be two lanes wide
at the moment it's only single Lane so
as you can see in the image on the left
you got two lores but you got a lot of
marking it's reduced to single what'll
happen is there'll be two lanes of
carriageway which will in significantly
increase
capacity there'll be some changes to the
road Arrangement towards clayon in terms
of you'll see at the top here at the
moment there's uh a lot of segregated
land with the Chevrons that you can't
cross that'll be adjusted in order to
create a second approach Lane onto the
junction when you are traveling from the
East and then that section in red will
be
widened in order to increase capacity so
the parish councils all five local
Parish councils are now satisfied with
the improvements to Junction 52 they
have accepted that actually dueling part
of that is a significant
benefit the gipping Meadowland as shown
on the screen already a meadow so you
might think well what what benefit AR
derives from having it remain a nature
area well the benefit potentially is
that whether or not the council takes
the land for a pound it effectively will
manage it in future to a spe
specification that it feels is
appropriate
via a management plan that will be
presented to the owners and they will
have to implement it as set out and
we've already been having discussions
with our public realm team and our
ecology specialists in public realm
about enhancing the value of that site
in terms of Nature and
biodiversity without changing its
intrinsic qualities as a flood
Meadow so it's 8.8 hectares that could
potentially become another element in
the council's portfolio of green sites
that it manages for the benefit of
wildlife quick fly over we'll just
follow the railway this is the gipping
Meadowland you can
see part of the site is defined by the
river gipping and the railway on the the
other
side we've looked at ways with our
colleagues as how that can be improved
for recreational very informal
Recreation actually um some paths might
be created but large areas will
remain difficult to access in order to
encourage Wildlife to be
undisturbed so in a nutshell well what
what for me is a nutshell um that's a
quick run through the scheme just to
highlight the key elements our
recommendation is to Grand planning
permission subject to securing legal
agreements to secure all the items out
in the report and that members Grant
conditional full outline where relevant
and outline applic permission where
relevant thank you chair I'm happy and
willing to any questions that arise
thank you uh thank you very much for the
presentation um do we have any questions
of the case
officer councilor
Elkin thank you um can I just remind
everybody um that it's quite difficult
to hear um with the microphone so please
can you bring the mic as close as you
can and speak to the mic don't turn your
head to talk to me thank
you I'm not very loud either so if
anyone can't hear me please just wave at
me
um thank you it was just a question
about I think it's footpath
21 which goes through the site um and
what I just saw in one of the comments
that somebody had sent in was um saying
that it does currently connect to a
bridal way um and it was I think the
comment was from horse people who ride
on that Bridal way concern that they
wouldn't be able to now be able to get
through to get to the bridal way um but
I was just wondering as it's such a wide
green Corridor if there was any capacity
for it to be suitable for a sort of
mixed use of cycling and riding um which
would then connect through to that
Bridal way as well so that was that was
one
question the report includes a plan that
shows the exact position of bridleway 30
and footpath
21 the good news is that that green
Corridor will keep footpath 21 in
exactly the same place as it is it isn't
being obstructed or diverted but
effectively that whole strip will be
available for the public to use now our
colleagues in uh public rights away
haven't required that to be upgraded to
a brid way but there's no reason
why and I'm not a public rights away
specialist but if they're using the bits
that aren't the designated public
footpath then a horse could use it my
question might be why are they going
down there because they'll end up on the
brownford road and if they're not
careful Junction 52 but I mean as it is
technically possible yes but it isn't a
requirement to make it a brid way I was
thinking really more than the bridal way
of it being then potentially a cycle
route it would be if it
was so that was just one one question
um or did you have another question um
councelor Alin I thought you said you
had more than one yeah I did I um should
I go for it now um well councelor
hardingham had his hand up so perhaps
we'll come back to you thank
you do we have any more detail on the
plans for gipping Meadow um it seems to
me that as a existing flood Meadow um
which is only seasonally grazed it
probably has quite High Wildlife value
as it is um and I'm wondering um what
can be done to enhance that from a
practical point of view to produce much
benefit you are absolutely right it is
occasionally grazed what we are looking
at with our ecology and public realm
colleagues and the parish councils are
joining it is I think the grazing regime
will
continue there will be uh areas that are
fenced in order to keep the public out
there could be some additional planting
but whatever happens it would be agreed
with our public Realm team K and de the
parish councils and it would all be
directed at maintaining the current
value or enhancing it now that's a
weasly way of not answering your
question because the honest answer is we
haven't got that detail our public realm
colleagues are working on it but you can
make it absolutely clear that the if we
were if you were minded to Grant
permission and it was to be included in
the 106 we could have the 106 saying
that the objective shall be to do no
harm to the existing
value or enhance that existing value for
the purpose of Wildlife and biodiversity
because that is our
aim but we have got draft ideas but I
couldn't show you on the screen what
that means it's minimally invasive so it
might be keep it as it is for a number
of years until we really have thought
through the best way to to manage
it uh if I could just have a a followup
um I presume that we're looking for a
minimum 10% and the objective would be
for a 20%
BNG Improvement on the site as a whole
to include the actual development site
and also the meadow um that seems to me
a bit of a a tall ask because the the
development site itself is almost
entirely hardstanding roads parking and
roofs surprisingly there is a lot of
marginal land that's included that will
be enhanced we also secured significant
BNG on phase one there's a whole new
Plantation that's being planted up as we
speak to the West so you are right the
applicants will still need to
demonstrate 10% and that's a a a
condition we are expecting it to smash
that out of the out of the park and I
think you're Target of 20 is something
that I will be encouraging the
applicants to to meet and as you say the
Baseline for the gipping Meadow Land is
What it already is so it'll be 10% on
top of that or at least in aggregate the
two sites will have to meet a minimum of
10% thank you uh councelor
Davis uh thank you chair I uh saw with
interest about the lagoons and your wet
wood
area if is that by Design having and
part of the SS areas that are
permanently ponded with water or is it
going to be allowed to dry out as we go
through wet um dry periods Sor the
intention would be to have a a central
area that is permanently wet or at least
boggy um and then the rest will rise and
fall but is intended to have it as a wet
feature permanently or part of
it thank you U if we go back to counc
Elkin do you want to do a second
question and then I I think councel
matson's got a
question thank you it was um I think it
mentions the sort of skills and
education sort of intent to work with I
think the local suff one and um and
other organizations I just wondered if
we had any more detail about what that
might might look like or is that still
being sort of thought
through that's one where my colleague
Michelle might be able to to help us
because what we're trying to do is work
in across services to deliver or to
maximize opportunities for all of our
community Through planning applications
so if it's not unreasonable and through
you chair if if Michelle's willing to
chip in at the moment it's an aspiration
but we hope it'll become something more
then thank you
thank you chair excuse me um yeah we
have an intention to work alongside the
applicant to develop a an employment and
skills plan that would be signed off as
one of the conditions for the
application within that excuse me we
would set out with the applicant exactly
how they're going to engage with all of
the skills providers what types of
employment that will be offered on site
and and what the timeline for that
coming forward will be so that we can
try and support that and ensure that as
many local residents as possible have
access and the skills needed to be able
to take advantage of the jobs being
created on
site thank you uh councilor meon thank
you yeah if we could um come to the the
uh the cycle Network I mean the parking
is very impressive um but
the what what's concerning me a bit is
is that
the are we you know offsite improvements
to cycling um it's all very well linking
up to the ajacent Villages but they're
not really that populous and the larger
numbers of people are to be found in
ipswitch and I just
wonder if if
we whether the county highways have
asked for anything to be done because I
I I I've got a memory of of the CLE
between Branford and IPS which being
awful um and and someone telling me that
she wouldn't let her teenagers cycle it
etc etc um you know she was living in
Branford and they wanted to go whip
Swit and
um so so I just wondered what we're
getting to help that
cuz if you could if it's a mile away and
it's a love cycle route well yeah okay
maybe people might cycle but it can
almost walk that what what is your
question what the question really is can
we are we getting any Improvement for
people who are going to you know the
optimum cycling distance is is need a
minip switch to this site um really
they're the people we want to get out of
their cars are we getting any
improvements to the cycle route to IP
switch and to need them is the essential
question
as part of this application no the
reason being that as you will
recall whatever we ask for by way of
section 106 has to be reasonable and
reasonably related to the development
what we have secured if permission is is
granted is improvements along brownford
road which directly serve this
development I understand the point
you're making but this is something for
our colleagues at suffk County and
perhaps our own uh transport people
through the LC Whip or the transport
plan to identify major projects that
require significant investment so my
suggestion might be that you continue to
put a lot of pressure on our colleagues
at suffk highways and our own Katherine
Davis to see if we can extend projects
in the LC with
in order to secure that comprehensive
cycle Network to the major centers of
population I mean we are talking
millions and millions these are major
projects and I I'm sure you'll say well
if we can spend millions and millions on
roads let's spend millions of millions
on cycle way and I wouldn't necessarily
disagree but you can't require an
applicant on this doing a development of
this scale to provide improvements to
the system to if which it just wouldn't
be reasonable within the planning
sphere so unfortunately on this occasion
we can't require them to but I know lots
of people who we could contact to say
this came up at committee let's let's
see what we can do in terms of the OC
web the transport plan uh thank you
there there is of course a cycle way
from Witten to clayon so if you come
from IP switch you go from Wht to clayon
and then you pick up the route as
indicated on on the map that we were
shown uh you then talked about Branford
which is different I'll admit
um officer's gotor I don't yeah I think
um councelor Davis had his hand up again
I'm sorry if I've missed somebody else
can I also yeah I noticed that um
councelor Erin grimaced as uh nicely
grimaced as Michelle was talking about
how we would intend or try and develop
our employment scheme it looked as
though you thought that sounds like jam
tomorrow I just wonder if it was um no
grimacing intended sorry about that um
no it was it was just another follow on
maybe it's something for outside of here
just to ask sort of I'd be really
interested in the detail of that and
particularly how younger people can be
engaged and just speaking personally as
having a a very small uh Business Park
uh adjacent to my ward and it's
incredibly difficult for local people to
find out what jobs are available there's
no apprenti ships we don't have any uh
the high we have a high school but
there's very little work experience for
young people sort of on our little
business park so um you know if it could
be sort of all all the age groups
included that would be incredible but
yeah that that might be a a discussion
to have outside of the sphere Vince did
you want to come
back committee might like uh Michelle
and myself to report back at some future
committee where perhaps isn't the full
agenda just so that we can let you know
how well we've done to provide you with
the detail that you've asked for to make
an aspiration an
actuality thank you perhaps that that
that would might be welcome um so I
think there was councelor Davis I also
think there's councelor war boys so I'm
sorry I've I've missed you out councelor
War boys but I did say councelor Davis
next and then I'll come to
you uh thank you chair so on the subject
of um integrated transport again um we
talked a lot about by bikes there um and
you mentioned many millions of pounds so
what links are there potential with the
railway obviously be able to reduce the
number of lawers and Al likee I'm
excited at Prospect of electrically
powered Lis and those sorts of things
however that is a a brilliant point and
it's made me want to revisit the section
of the report where we talk about the
Fleet if if three vehicles can be a
fleet the fleet of electric shuttle
vehicles that Port one will be securing
because as part of the
offer K and D have said that there is
potential for local communities to have
access to
those um electric vehicles outside of
peak times for for Port one there is no
reason why
potentially uh they couldn't be
shuttling local communities to the
station for example we have tried to
come up with a system whereby local
people could be shuttled to the um need
and Market GP surgery but at the moment
that practice is not seemingly willing
to talk to us about about that but we
won't give up that's one element of
course there's nothing stopping the
shuttle vehicle from picking up members
of staff at the station and bringing
them to the thing so within the 106 we
are looking to flesh out the nature of
that arrangement but certainly Kur and
de have said yes they're happy to
consider how that works in a sense
they've got the vehicles the electricity
is free in a sense because of all the PV
that they're putting on why not open it
up to um the communities to
[Music]
improve connectivity without having to
rely on the
car thank
you uh councelor War
boys
thank you um yeah on um page 106 our
corporate manager for economy and
business introduces a bit of a
cautionary note uh about the um
limitations if you like of the
monoculture of logistics Parks uh and
I'm aware this is um Cen
de's business and um it fits very well
in with Port one but my question is are
we not on page 106 146 sorry you we have
B an explanation of this and control
over use and it limits this development
to to B8 which is actually
warehousing my question is how we not
just sort putting the the lid on any
possible diversification
on this site in terms of whether there
is some assembly of manufacturing or
value added um activity going on which
will if you like benefit the local
economy and the the range of jobs
available possibilities for
trading I I absolutely understand the
point you're making and it is a it is a
good one I would argue we are not
putting the lid on diversification what
we are doing is introducing an ability
for us to manage that in a way that
means let's say it was B1 or
B2 we would want to ensure that the off
street
parking requirement was met
because um office let's say office or
industry has a much higher parking
requirement than warehousing so what I'm
saying is in order to allow those units
to be used for let's say B1 uses well
what were B1 uses you'd have to provide
more parking how would they achieve that
what we don't want then to do is to have
cars parking on the estate Road and the
joining roads so it's simply saying if
you want to change the use you'd have to
come back to us so look andure you meet
our current standards what I am also
saying though and it is putting a lid on
is what we wouldn't want for example is
for these units to become let's say
retail units because under Class
E um you can change use to a multitude
of uses so one of those is retail well
the last thing we probably want in terms
of protecting Nom and other centers is
to have an outof Town retail Center so
in that sense we're putting the lid on
it but all we're saying in terms of uh
employment uses generally is we need to
be able to ensure that you meet our
standard relevant standards for that
particular type of use now the
difference between Port one and our own
site at Gateway 14 is that Gateway 14
does have a general permission for
employment uses but our colleagues are
ensuring that parking there meets the
requirements so if somebody wants a B2
unit General industrial unit they're
going to have to provide the requisite
requisite parking but Port one is
purpose-built logistics
Park thank you for exping on thank you
um Council
Lawrence thank you chair um probably a
bit of a confusing question uh we
welcome normally welcome uh the
provision of jobs I think it was
something like over 12200 jobs is
envisaged in this part alone I'm
interested to know what is the travel to
work area en Visage to support to obtain
that number of jobs only on last night's
news only 4% is unemployment in East
Anglia at the moment and it's not a lot
of good if people are going to travel 30
you know if they've Trav work areas 30
or 40 miles to achieve those numbers so
that's the first part but interrelated
is to supply those numbers of people in
a limited travel to work area do we have
a strategy of Housing Development
nearby without again people traveling 30
or 40 miles to
work taking your first
point first I think that might be a
question you want to direct to the
applicants because I know they have uh
done a lot of research in terms of where
the existing staff come from in terms of
their catchment in order to satisfy us
on parking
requirements they are recruiting a
significant number locally now whether
they can sustain that I'll leave that
perhaps to them to answer if you ask
them direct and your second point which
is now completely just gone out of my
mind as I was trying to write the the
answer sufficient housing capacity
that's right in the near area I'd be
very surprised if there was a counselor
within the district that said we haven't
secured sufficient housing in our joint
local plan to ensure that we've covered
that angle I mean in close proximity
we've still got some development going
on Nan will have more Stow Market will
have more elmswell is getting something
I'm pretty certain that we are we can
guarantee that we're going to keep
building houses for the next plan period
and because this site is so close to the
Stow Market need them the big centers of
population I think we're going to keep
up it's the jobs in a way that we need
to ensure that the jobs are keeping up
with the residential rather than the
other way
around thank
you um well can I just ask a question I
oh did did you have a question councilor
Morgan sorry you're you need to wave a
bit more thank you
hello my count my question is about the
tenure of the Freehold of ging Meadow is
there a fixed term of years stated on
the agreement because if the council can
buy it for a pound you don't want to
find that in 10 years time you suddenly
have to go back and renegotiate this
having given all the
permission it would be the Freehold in
perpetuity for a
pound
did you have another question Council
just can you remind us I was thinking
about um the you know what the remarks
about the LC Whip and the cycling uh can
you remind us about the seal um status
of the um of the
application do you mean do you mean will
it be paying any sale I do essentially
well that's the question then
yeah that's a question that's just
caught me on the Hop
because this sort of development didn't
traditionally trigger sill but I know
we've just we're in the process or have
just changed that so that all
development can I quickly look behind
the scenes councelor maton and come back
to you it's a good yeah yeah thank you
for the for the leeway to check that out
thank
you do do you want a bit of uh a bit of
time now or
or has has Gemma got it up already um a
minute or two whether you want to carry
on them well I just wanted to I had my
own question actually about the highway
improvements on the junction whatever it
is 50 whatever uh is there a timing
condition about when all those
improvements to that Junction are to be
implemented um and and do we have a sort
of rough time scale I mean should should
this application get permission um um
when are we going to expect another load
of Road works on the A4 that that's
really my
question where you minded well if we
Grant planning permission unit five
would be built almost straight away
suffer County Council have said no more
units then unit 5 can be occupied until
such time as all the necessary
improvements are in
place so the record of Kur and de is the
buildings go up very quickly
particularly where they have a tenant
they've always had a tenant in advance
none of this is speculative so I would
expect those Works to be happening on
Junction
[Music]
52 well sometime after 12 months but
that might be a question you ask
directly to the the applicant because I
suspect their work program has already
factored that in yeah I know I I they
obviously have to get permission from
highways England presumably as well
because no it's not even though it's not
on the on the APR just suff County
Council yeah interestingly the whole
Junction 52 is managed
by suff County
[Music]
Council has has JMA managed to find the
answer about the seal question I think
so chair thank you um so it's always
complicated with Sal just bear with me a
sec so it is sale liable as a
development but the liability charge is
zero so yes and no in to that one I'm
afraid it may be and I'm looking at the
current one which is 2016 we haven't got
an updated version available currently
it may be that that rate changes in the
future but at the moment the S liability
rating is a zero pound if you're resi
you're looking at anywhere between 50
to15 pounds per square meter your s
liability but this has got a zero pound
rating despite being liable but I
appreciate that's a bit of a complicated
version I must admit I thought it
wouldn't be paying sale but um you've
confirmed that
um any further questions of the
officer if not then we will uh move on
to public speakers um so I would like to
invite Mr binder from Little blakenham
Parish Council um if you would like to
um speak into the you need to press the
button on the mic speak as clearly as
you can into the mic um and I will time
you for three minutes thank you
yes good morning Madam chairman and
counselors I'm Wally Bar chairman of uh
little Blen and Parish Council I've been
involved with the council since about
1970 and and uh witnessed several
variations to the site it was originally
going to be a golf course and that fell
out of bed and uh then it was going to
be a greenhouse development and that
fell out of bed and now we've got this
development and and uh as far as the
village is concerned and I speak for
them uh you maintain our
footpath you're giving us Wildlife ponds
and um areas for uh development of of
wildlife in in woods and trees and
things and you're building a large bond
to protect the B Beach's development
which would Overlook the um site if it
wasn't for the band
and we congratulate the developers on
what they've done for us and thank them
very much thank you thank
you um do we have any questions uh of uh
Mr
binder thank you very much if you'd like
to turn your microphone off
um um we don't have another one of those
do we uh uh right so we don't have an
objector or a support reporter uh we
have Mr Davey who is speaking on behalf
of the applicant or are you the
applicant um I just need to wait for my
timer to um drip Through Time on my
laptop oh yeah okay okay um committee
Clark is going to time you so you can
start whenever you're ready um thank you
very much Mr Davey thank you uh members
uh I'm the agent for the application but
I do have the applicant with me and we'd
be very happy to take questions at the
end um and I'll try and uh address some
of the questions uh in what I'm going to
say now um I'd like to start by thanking
officers uh and the officers in your
community team for facilitating
discussions with the five Parish
councils which have helped resolve all
of their concerns and have uh resulted
in offers to install photo voltaic cells
on the roofs of each Paris Hall and to
contribute to the building of a new Hall
at little blam all to be secured by
section
106 um in my experience it's very rare
to have that level of support for a size
and complexity of application of this
type and from behalf of Port one we're
committed to continuing to work with the
local community into the
future um there are of course other
benefits and we've discussed some of
those the creation of the new public
Nature Reserve at M Lane which I can
confirm will be maintained in perpetuity
from the port one service charge by Port
one to the direction of the council and
will always be available for purchase to
one pound um creation of up to 100 sorry
1,250 new jobs in 40 different trades
many in Hightech sectors and of high
worth um also the potential to save 40
jobs which would otherwise be lost
following the closure of the Magnus
group um that firm has been bought out
by the tenant who's going into unit
five um the commitment to work with the
council to provide training mentoring
and support to local people to access
new jobs
we've spoken about the offsite
pedestrian and cycle connectivity
improvements we also have the electric
minius service which runs fre for staff
we're currently doing a circular route
into it switch and to the railway
station bringing staff in and there's
going to be two additional mini buses
running that route and as and when staff
move around we'll look look at the route
that that runs over time um there's also
of course 7.5 million annual rates
payable by the time this development is
completed
um we spoken about the increasing the
capacity of Junction 52 we think that
will be done by or what will commence on
that this year um and when it's finished
Junction 52 will have greater capacity
than it does now even after taking into
account the
development um we hope to generate 100%
of the energy needs of a standard
Logistics Park from roof mounted fto Bic
cells that would include for the
Lighting electric only fork lifts uh and
the e V charging uh which is double the
prescribed amount as a minimum and there
are will be very significant
biodiversity enhancements we're planting
we think 2 and a half thousand new trees
that's in addition to the 175,000 sorry
25,000 new trees in addition to the 17 a
half thousand have already been planted
in current phases uh and of course
creating that wet wood P one is a
success story are you about to finish
yeah has been built to the specific
requirements of the tenants and that
will continue nothing speculative and I
would also point out something that
hasn't propped up 90% of that site
already has planning permission for
development either for Port one or for
the green houses um so if we can take
any questions we'll be happy to do
so uh thank you very much uh do we have
any questions of Mr Davey uh C Harding
yeah I would like to ask um about tomato
green houses they were originally going
to be connected to the incinerator plant
um to make use of the waste heat um and
uh I would have thought this would be a
a a good thing to safeguard in the
future um would this development make it
impossible to connect the tomato green
houses to the waste heat I mean as in
the
future I mean as I understand the if
they need to make A5 million pound
investment in that uh plant before they
can transport the waste heat um they
have been discussion with Port one to
take that heat um so if the green houses
can't use it Port one will try and use
it
yeah thank you thank you um councilor
Davis uh thank you chair a couple of
questions one uh are you envisaging any
uh battery storage capacity capacity so
that you can harvest the energy I I'll
hand over to Mr
Maxwell uh yes we are in fact um
obviously with the solar power that's
been generated on the
roofs you you get with solar power this
latitude variations of um generation so
that people can either tenants can
either export back into the grid and
then obviously in what I call the dark
months import so it's Z balance or they
can do their own battery storage as well
one of the things that we have secured
is a major uh Power availability from um
the Branford substation which is
available to us in mid
2025 from um EDF Renewables and that is
our next phase where we'd like to then
offer that for um electric vehicle
charging for commercial vehicles so we
want to promote that as
well thank you many thanks my next
question is probably uh little bit uh
Blue Sky maybe um there's some work been
done at Reading university looking at
using Ivy to produce a green wall on the
sides of buildings now clearly on not
all of your uh warehousing walls it
wouldn't be appropriate to consider but
perhaps on one or two it may be worth
investigating whether or not using a
green uh
vegetation may be worthwhile I see you
are very open-minded to exploring these
sorts of things and looking to
absolutely absolutely anything that is
uh something which could assist in the
overall development make it Greener
we're happy to do that and promote
it well thank you it has the advantage
of reducing summer temperatures yes and
also providing some warmth in the winter
yes better insallation
yes thank you uh any further
questions uh cast Lawrence I think you
know my question what is your plan
travel to work area for this development
then and I I did note that the agent did
say that there was going to be a bus
service to IPS um electric bus service
which I
welcome in in last August we we did a
detailed survey working with all of the
various I
um districts and within a 50 minute
drive people seeking job seeking
allowance was
210,00 people that was from August data
obviously as the radius comes in and in
figures come down but looking at a 30
minute drive at the moment from December
Figures it's 22,800 people looking for
work in that
location that would be suitable for this
type of uh facil here at the moment
there's 40 different trades on Port one
we think that would probably go to about
60 um I take on board the B8 element but
for instance if you look at the L
wheeler there's a whole raft of
Industries within that business that you
don't actually know you just think it's
a warehouse operation and an office
operation but there's a broking
operation in there there's a similiar
operation there's photography there's
whole various forms of different tra
within these buildings but predominantly
there still be8
use and in in terms of planning
permission the current phase one is for
B2 B8 so there is a mix of uses within
the current phase but it's the market
that has sort of pushed it more to to
the B8
use thank you uh councilor oin thank you
um with the um it's great that there's
going to be so much uh solar PV on on
the roofs I just wondered if you
anticipated having any spare roof space
or is it all going to be needed to
produce the energy you need on
site um we think we can generate about
five megawatt from what you see with
that existing application there um there
there would be a small amount of roof
space left for various other um
operations if necessary but there will
be a little piece left here but that's
likely to be oh the reason I was asking
was if you're going to have a sort of
ample amounts of spare whether could be
you know for example a community energy
project using your roof space but it
sounds like you've you've got plans for
all of it um I think the intention would
be to just try and get to the fact that
there a carbon neutral facility and then
if we can do anything else in the future
that's obviously we're open to look at
various
ideas thank you um any more questions
thank you very much um um do we have any
comment from the Ward
member I I haven't received anything I
just wondered if you'd had
anything no I think it's councelor marot
is
it no chair we've not had any
correspondence from
counc uh well in that case I will now
open this item Up For
Debate before we
start we we also need to get home um but
yeah two minutes no you mustn't talk
about the
C
was that your hand going up uh councelor
Harding because you wanted to speak
first uh well I I just wondered whether
I just noticed that uh I've got
something written down in my notebook
here um a question I haven't asked the
agent um which was um about the S scheme
um and obviously I'm I'm very
enthusiastic about um possibility of wet
Woodland um but it seems to me that
might not be the whole of the SS um
provision and I was wondering what
proportion of um other other Suds
provision there is in addition to that
and whether some of that is
crates
um I I I think our officer can answer
that actually about whether there's more
SS thank
you the majority of the suds element
within this phase I showed on the screen
you're quite right councel hardingham
each Warehouse unit will have a crate
system under the parking
area that will eventually feed clean
water into the drainage
lagoons so the answer is it's a hybrid
scheme it's not a full sud scheme and it
isn't a a non s scheme it is a
hybrid does that answer your
question well it was really really about
the maintenance of crate s schemes in
the long run and what the provision is
for making sure that they they do indeed
get desilted or replaced or rebuilt in
as appropriate can answer to that one I
can by
saying that's a very good point why
don't if members are mind need to Grant
planning permission why don't we as part
of the drainage details require a
maintenance plan to be agreed with the
llfa so that we can come back to you
later councel and say actually there's a
program that requires xmon X year review
sortation desolation process it's
probably the first time anyone's ever
asked that question it seems an
eminently sensible one and I I I know
that K and de will work with us to come
up with that regime um in partnership
with our colleagues at suff County as so
if you're minded then happy to add a
condition to that effect thank
you okay um uh is there so we're now in
the debate um phase of this application
so uh would anyone like to uh contribute
councilor Davis thank you very
much
um reading the details on this obviously
there's uh a large roof expanse uh lots
of uh concrete standing areas so on the
one hand you sort of go oh goodness me
and then you get into thinking about all
the the new jobs the remedial activity
and the uh whole approach that this
developer has taken which is really
Cooperative supportive and um
open-minded so I'm quite excited by this
project and would uh be very willing to
enthusiastically support the
recommendation of our planning
officer thank you anybody else wish to
uh say anything councelor warboys
thank you chair yeah uh yeah I I do have
some uh reservations but I think I think
they're not really relevant to this
application but there something that
needs to be thought about outside this
meeting um I think one of the one of
those reservations however is about
diversification diversity that's as
important in um the environment in
Woodland but it's just as important in
business and employment and
Society um so I think my reservation is
about the sort of
monoculture nature of this development
however but if we look at the overall
strategy across M suffer this is
balanced by the opportunities at Gateway
14 and perhaps
puts even more pressure on Gateway 14 to
provide a more
diverse
um um range of
opportunities I think K and de I have
visited um the present buildings at Port
one I think K and D have shown
really a great deal of skill they've
produced a quality um
Logistics part uh their ability to sort
of realize that is without doubt um I
think you know the the way they've
extended that ethos if you like into
sort of sustainability photo volte cells
engagement the community and the level
of thought that has gone into mitigation
for these big
sheds uh in particular the possib ility
of the wet woodlands and circular Parks
which take circular walks which take us
back to where we started from
um it's it's a it's a great
opportunity
um I I I think we could I think i' I'd
be in favor of approving this and I'd
like to propose that we do approve this
S I think if more developers came
forward the same degree of Engagement
with our officers the communities we'd
have a a a better place if you like
thank thank you um um Council War boys
um uh I I'll just check see if we have a
second uh um are you taking on board the
suggestion of another condition about
maintenance of the
wet Wetland Suds whatever you want to
call it yes I think that's um and did I
see a little hand wve from Council Davis
you're happy to Second very much chair
thank you yeah thank you very much so
that is as per the offic of
recommendation plus the uh some sort of
condition about maintenance of the um
drainage system clear Council hingham's
point was about the crates rather than
the drainage
basin councilor hardingham yeah I no the
case officer mentioned um the
possibility of reversing the the banding
on the buildings on the East West Route
um I wondered if that's something that
we discuss now um or whether that's left
as as I understand it was weren't those
buildings part of the outline or are
they part of the full and if they're
outline should we be determining the
color of the painting if they're not
there
yet it's a bit of each because one of
the buildings is actually along that
that route my thought was it would be
left to us as officers and the chief
planning officer just to work out
whether that makes sense
overall so so is there a condition about
the um out you know the the color of the
walls or to be determined to be to be
agreed by the planning department or
something there isn't reference to that
particular route at the moment it's
everything will be the darkest band at
the top but it may be that the
recommendation is that the officers give
consideration to reversing the banding
along footpath
yep that seems perfectly um does that uh
is that okay with our second our
proposal and our
second okay um councilor Matson yeah I
mean the the I think the we we have to
place our our trust in in in the
planning officers and and all the
consules um that that that this is you
know a good job has been done here and
certainly it all looks looks that way to
me I think the just just to come back to
the question earlier about are there
enough people round about um there is
the council has a particular duty to
cooperate in the jargon um and um I I do
know that the there was quite a lot of
anxiety about the enormous number of
houses that were um being permitted and
applied for across
both sides of the boundary between midu
and babber at this point and I think I'd
ref reference a
spron and um was it was it P a couple of
villages so a lot of houses going that
side and in fact there's quite a lot of
houses going into into clayden and Barum
and they're not all built yet but
they're on their way so I I don't think
there's any concern that there's not
enough people around um and um I think
that you know I'll be continuing to
press um County highways as as to what
constitutes the
necessary um offsite improvements
because if we're going to decarbonize
travel then um we are going to need to
to look at those things and and it's
great that there's going to be electric
buses picking people up from
ipswitch um but you know we want people
to be able to cycle as well cycling is
good for you I'm not sure the chair will
agree with this um so that's that's
something to return to but so I really
um I think the you know it has to go
ahead um so I'll be voting in favor
thank you uh anyone else
um ready to say anything councilor Elkin
thank you it was just very briefly just
to say yes is exciting to see a a a
ambition to be a a carbon neutral
Logistics Park um and all the care
that's obviously been taken to work with
uh to have all I think all of the parish
councils being supportive is is really
lovely um very briefly I think I
mentioned right at the start about um
whether there was any value in being
able to cycle on along that footpath 21
and I don't know the area I haven't
cycled in the area so I defer to my
experienced cycling colleagues if that
doesn't add anything in terms of
connectivity maybe that's not something
we need to discuss any further but I
just wanted to mention it before we kind
of get to
voting thank you um anyone else wish to
say anything um if not maybe I'll I'll
say my piece that that we do we do need
um you know economic development in our
in our patch and I think that this is is
a good place for ITC you know it it's
adding on to an existing um employment
area um all the parish councils locally
are on board with it so you could say
that this is in the right place and
added to that um all these environmental
credentials are just fantastic um and
and yeah I do share my concerns with
councelor Matson about about cycle
access but I understand that there's
limitations as to what what we can do in
in this particular situation um I'm not
that familiar with cycling land little
blakenham um I looked on the OS map and
and and that path and the path behind
there both look like public foot paths
although one of the is a track that I am
familiar with because I think it used to
go to Blake and chalk pits where I used
to do um conservation work um and it's
it turns into a sort of you know it's a
it's a Tac road that goes around the
back so yes it would be cyclable but I
don't think it's legally cyclable um and
I that again that may be something that
you want to be determined by the local
Parish councils if it is worthy of uh
making that a loop um fit for bikes but
I I I I'd like to congratulate the devel
ER on on the parish aison and the um
carbon neutrality of the site um and I
welcome it and I will be in support of
this application thank you uh does
anyone else wish to say
anything W
voice yeah thank you chair just need I
just need to come back a bit I think
there was a condition regarding the
lighting along brownford Road that was
recommended in orders this will sort of
mitigate the sort of
um effects on the housing along
brownford Road all lighting is subject
to further condition you're you're right
one to ensure that it's um mildlife
friendly but also to ensure that it
doesn't give rise to
nuisance on the subject of conditions
we've talked about adding some more
conditions onto the uh list that you've
extensive list you've got at the end of
your report which is split into the um
two parts of the full and the outline so
do all of these new newly added
conditions go on both sections just want
to check that that they are relevant for
both
um and they will be added to both
hopefully um it is anybody else need to
say anything or um could we just read
out what the um what we're actually
going to be voting on in due course
thank you yeah thank you chair so we're
looking at approving as the
recommendation which is set out on your
papers in pages 156 to 159 with
additional conditions for the
maintenance and phasing plan for created
surface water drainage and for officers
to give consideration to reversing the
banding along footpath 21 hope that's
everything
so is that is that correct proposal in
seconda you happy with
that uh right so I will now ask the
government's officer to uh conduct the
electronic vote thank you chair members
that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is eight votes for
so that's unanimous uh thank you um so
uh that brings us to the end of our uh
agenda uh we've just got item number
eight site inspections do any inspection
requests need to be reported to
committee uh n reive
chair so in which case I will close this
meeting at
12:22 uh the next meeting of the
planning committee will be on the 14th
of February at 9:30 a.m. here in the
King Edmund chamber so
um